travel generates money it generates jobs
it generates economic growth these are
all good things of course
however
and the United Nations has released a
key report on climate change we need a
Quantum Leap in climate action to combat
what we've done just one round trip
transatlantic flight emits twice as much
carbon dioxide emissions as driving the
family car for an entire year this week
alone more than 90 thousand people came
to Hawaii as visitor numbers continue to
increase so does the amount of garbage
found along our shorelines these popular
stops are sacred I hope it's awesome
it's us that we need to do more to save
this 100 said yeah
[Music]